a little hot reject nation that's Greg
Albee here I've been pretty sick
actually the past few days since like
Tuesday there's a ring in my ear that
has not stopped for about five days
tried all kinds of experiments cuz I'm a
guy nods wait wait for deal I've even
shot some videos but didn't between a
lot of those jump cuts I'm like huh
manatee a little rest
you might hear to my voice so today I
went to Urgent Care got some
prescription that I got an ear fish
which the things going on man I was a
painful cleaning out the ear processes
anyway there's all leading up to there
was one day where I was really sick that
I I watched the first four episodes of
stranger things season two it's pretty
cool man I'm loving where the shows at
since I figured I'm just gonna have to
rest for a while I catch up on stranger
things the rest of season two with you
guys since I'm sure all of you have
already seen it and I'm on Episode five
it's called Dig Dug I think I could show
like ten minutes of footage record the
whole thing
I'll show you ten minutes let's face it
guys
they changed Elevens hair because they
saw me the creators of this show saw me
[Music]
look I don't want your ten minutes all
right kid
ten minutes or your religious
mumbo-jumbo whatever you're selling I
ain't buying okay she does the lock
thing this is so scary the truth I want
to see you're about to get your heart
broken 11:00 okay he's got to find out
about all this at some point all right
the brain yeah I do like it's Kyra doing
ever so yeah I do like why exactly I
told you the rules no questions we just
need you to help us figure out the
objective find X yeah
what's at the edge pirate treasure pop
no questions
that's the worst lie I've ever seen they
don't go over water and that's the
giveaway that's a giveaway whoa whoa all
of Hawkins
I love her hair
season one callback
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's really really it's just the wiring
[Music]
it's mama okay
[ __ ] picked up on that alors good good
job show
good job show what are you gonna do it
you got talking the upside down iron
ship to get that static going let's get
that static TV going
to talk
[Music]
she bet to see her Albert
[Music]
what a trippy experience to see yourself
people mothers perspective no oh this
guy I'm sure he's still got a nice check
for showing up
oh this is cool all the words she was
saying are are actually a slore yeah
everything went down
mama origins
[Music]
[Music]
how'd she make it up there
that's that girl for the first episode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the left bravely probably never go back
to normal
[Music]
[Music]
that is so sad that nothing kind of
makes me want to cry a little bit
I love David hard really more to see
Japan because you're like season what
David Harbor was feel like he doesn't
really have something to live for
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
did good spy
[Music]
[Music]
he's that connected to it
[Music]
damn job digging it I'm digging it I
feel like eventually all these stories
have to become fully connected the kid
who plays will what's his name MD ba it
should be right here will buyers know a
snap know a snap this kid I'm so glad
that he is a really good actor he was
barely in season one so it's like yeah
he's will but he kind of I kind of beat
him like that other guy in the hangover
trilogy who's not really a part of the
gang I don't know that actor's name you
know how in the hangover there's that
dude who's missing and then the main
cast the main gang is trying to find him
but you don't really consider the guy
that they find to be part of the main
game you don't really care for him to
show up and hangover 2 & 3 I was hoping
that he okay with season 2 will was
really left out of season 1 a lot for
obvious reasons he's missing that he
would be do a really good job and get a
lot more screen time and I feel kind of
sorry for this guy because out of all
the boys on the show I feel like he has
the character that has to just suffer so
much and I thought hardest emotional
challenges but man is he delivering dude
he could do creepy weird stuff I mean he
was just like the physical movement when
he's switching out at the end is great
being traumatized and just wanting to be
treated like he's normal is fantastic
the kids so good and I'm glad he's
getting a lot more screen time in the
show I have a lot of like where exactly
is this show going I'm on the fifth
episode and it feels like everyone's
stories are very divided so I know you
know if it's a good stranger thing
season or any good show eventually this
all comes full circle by the end of the
season or they all eventually become
fully connected because you know you got
Nancy and Jonathan they're off on their
mission trying to take down the man take
down the corporation and then Dustin and
Steve are now dealing with the creature
which name I forgot off the top of my
head the dog that one will Mike Joyce
hopper and out Bob are all dealing with
that tunnel situation there's just a lot
of different stories and there's even
more than that you gotta start with max
I
know who exactly why exactly dr.
Montgomery's in this show I don't know
who this character is it's weird because
I think daiquiri Montgomery is doing a
really good job playing him but I really
can't see the purpose that he serves in
this show other than this random
additional storyline and try to make the
inclusion of Mack's feel more dramatic
in a good way
I like the flirty tension between Dustin
Lucas and max but I'm really still
unsure how I feel about having max I
think she's good he's a good addition
but I don't really care about the folk a
lot of these exercise focusing really
seemed too significant to me but who
knows maybe by the time the show wraps
up it will feel that way I figure since
I haven't been sharing my thoughts and
the season on how I feel about the
season so far
share that with you guys first in terms
of this episode man a lot has been
revealed and you guys already know
what's coming next before I do so in
this episode with Jonathan and Nancy I'm
kind of at a point where I'm like dude
you guys just cut past the BS and start
hooking up with each other already
what's the what's the deal here Dustin
my favorite one actually he's the
funniest one so he's my favorite one
this mistake that he's made of bringing
the whatever into the picture it's kind
of it's it kind of gets on my nerves a
little bit maybe got a cat killed I feel
like a lot of the kids are making
mistakes and I like that I like when
characters make mistakes
Lucas sharing the big secret when max
dusty try to solve this problem and
teaming up with Steve I feel like those
two together
dynamite chemistry man I really feel
that that's it's gonna be so awesome to
see I'm hoping that the rest of this
show progresses with them being side by
side for a good amount of it and then
also another storyline that's kind of
its own direction is 11:11 it's not
really with the gang she's really doing
her own thing right now something tells
me that she probably won't reunite with
the gang until maybe the last episode or
second-to-last episode something like
that is what I imagine they're doing
with her we're getting like 11 origins
in the middle of all this other stuff
going on which is cool because 11 was
such a big mystery and now this time
we're explaining her backstory all this
stuff with her mom man that broke my
heart when I was when I was watching her
go through that now that broke my heart
you know I felt like maybe they did some
mind trick thing on her and there's a
way to bring her back but if they did
all that like lobotomy kind of stuff on
her I don't
there's a way should she never come back
to normal and clearly she has that power
at clueless she has a power like how her
daughter does with that amount of brain
damage that that was like that that
really was heartbreaking what I like
about it is this first half of the
season has really been making me go
where exactly is this show going and I
feel like this has reached a good
midpoint of really understanding like
this is just as well structured show
with Bob finding out what's going on bob
was kind of conflicting for me at first
cause I'm like why is this guy so why is
he always so nice and now that he's
included in the midpoint of the season
great job on the show that's
like--that's that makes sense the middle
of the show that's when the character
would be included will we've really
confirmed that he is hyper connected to
whatever is going on with the upside
down because it looked like he was
feeling those burns when that was
happening cuz you know of course they're
casting Sean Astin in it he's credited
in the titles of the show of course he's
gonna find out eventually and I thought
that was all handled really well and it
just makes you love Bob even more he
seems like the perfect dude to be cast
to it is he's kind of you seem like a
stereotype at first super nice guy think
it's called Bob Newby come on just such
a sweetheart kind of fella for Joyce and
Joyce is all crazy and traumatized and
she's probably more than hopper than she
is into this bob guy but over time you
know you really get to see this this
really full dimensional character and I
really love seeing Shaun acid in the
show that's pretty scary stuff to find
out that map was showing the entirety of
Hawken show gets so intense the show
gets is way too intense right now man
the first few episodes have built up a
lot of questions a lot of mystery and
now I feel like we're entering territory
of answers and understanding direction
of where they were going with certain
characters the only one who likewise
written this gentleman Zachary
Montgomery only want a prod Katina is
one day at a time some people love to do
the Netflix binge and they do the rift
live streams I might riff live stream
The Punisher maybe I'll be taking these
just one day at a time and it's gonna be
time to absorb the episode ever I think
yes you're coming in my name is 11
subscribe to the real rejects you
beautiful bastard
check out Philip defranco's channel he
paid me five thousand dollars to promote
him right now
because he definitely needs the
following from this channel